a comedy boom folks yeah do you feel
that I feel it yeah now I worry it'll go
away I know that's my fear you've been
through so many booms want two booms
well your family was in Oppenheimer
no that's Japanese wrong Asian yeah yeah
um no I've been through the Dark Ages
yeah yeah that's what I'm telling you've
never been through a Dark Age not really
no yeah they're depressing yeah yeah
when Eddie Griffin comes in and does two
hours yeah but it's gonna be also you
and I will do maybe clubs again whoa
it's gonna go down eventually it might
of it has to yeah yeah you mean I might
be like at the Sacramento punch line
yeah and I'll see Norman and morale I
mean next it'll be depressing yeah but
you know you gotta enjoy the run while
it is it's better to have loved you
gotta live in the moment
but I think it's I think it's still on
the rise really yeah great we're not at
a slump yet okay I'll call you when
we're on a slump please do yeah yeah
I I don't know I think the next slump
I'm out really really yeah I don't know
I I don't think I can hang on for
another 10 15 years for the next rise
right right because it's hard to get out
of that nosedive yeah it's a lot more
work I went through a lot wait what was
the reason for the um the most recent
slump what do you mean comedy slump the
night when I started was the slump right
I remember when I first met you it was
pretty Grim no yeah well other people
were doing but good that wasn't we were
in like a national slump I was just
having a slump oh personal no there's a
person was in a slump too what The
Comedy Store was Grim oh yeah that was a
slump yeah you're right yeah so there
was a slum yeah yeah you know what
you're right Live Comedy was in a slump
it's only I never actually was alive
when it was actually a Heyday well the
80s was the Heyday the Seinfeld what's
the deal with they put a microphone
anywhere yeah it would show up yeah then
it died in the early 90s yes that and
then I started in 95. and then it so I I
guess I started in the slump you know I
mean and then I had my own personal
little slumps but I would still see
other people do well like you know Dan
did well yeah you see certain guys do
well but um that's that's like Dane's
kind of saved it that's why I don't give
[__] to these popular hot guys because
they're bringing more people in I love
it I love it I love them I love it too
yeah I mean I I've but I've also never
been one of those guys like why is that
guy you know no no have you nah I don't
I don't know I like anybody who likes to
do stand-up should do it they're not all
great but yeah yeah you know you got to
be able to do it if you want are you
helpful with young people coming in yeah
I try to let them I do the uh like make
them open all that stuff oh yeah yeah
it's fun we're like because I get out of
this a lot hey I'm thinking about doing
it uh you encourage that I don't know
get the hell out of it what do you mean
what do you mean I didn't I'm thinking
about doing it either if you want to do
it you do it you know no one's like I'm
thinking about getting some [__] no you
just go get [__] yeah you want it yeah
yeah we have a try yeah try to get the
[__] try to get the [__] yeah yeah
it's the same with uh hey can I get a
buy a cup of coffee and pick your brain
what are you gonna pick oh yeah oh dude
I've gotten that too that's the word
let's get it also it's like [__] I'm
busy yes I don't have coffee with
Santino why would I have coffee with you
[__] exactly exactly why are you
smiling I'm agreeing yeah yeah yeah
people go yeah can I can I have a little
bit of your time the worst is that so
you I don't know if you get this um
after a show I'll see a guy with
something in his hand and I can always
know guess what it is uh this is this so
this is the guy just look right I
already know not a head shot no a gift a
script oh
oh that's an LA thing we don't have that
New York no you don't have that we got
like a Percocet but no uh nobody's
writing scripts over there right all
right I've no but I've gotten that like
in the midwest oh really I wrote meet
you and Andrew a movie oh I mean Android
was like okay we'll read it trash can
what route should he have taken what
what route should he have taken how does
he shoot a shot with you a guy with a
script it's a good question oh that's
interesting um he really just is like
being bold well here's what you do you
pull a Lorn spender what's that oh Pulp
Fiction
reservation dogs Reservoir
we did a double
[Laughter]
oh so this is what happened so
um Tarantino was sleeping on Lauren
Bender's couch right and he wrote I
guess this is probably a myth but he
wrote it on a like a napkin or like just
a bunch of napkins and random pieces of
paper but Lawrence was going through to
acting class right back then now
Lawrence is a producer yep and so um he
gave it to the acting his acting teacher
but then his acting teacher read it and
liked it and sent it to New York now I
guess they have the same acting studio
in New York maybe the actor Studio I
think it's something like that and
Harvey Keitel happened to be there with
the other acting in New York and the guy
read it and they gave it to Harvey oh
wow I tell Reddit and goes this is
unbelievable and then called Lawrence
and then Tarantino wasn't even supposed
to direct it wow but by the end he I
guess he just campaign campaigned
because I know every shot this and that
and they gave it to him but my point is
is that Tarantino was just sleeping on
his cat and Lauren Spencer's couch but I
love it what he already have that
connection then if you're just a guy
from the Midwest with a script and
dreams like you're not sleeping on
anyone's you know what I mean like you
just you have no connection to LA or to
an acting school or today it wasn't
Lawrence Bender was a producer then he
was just a guy yeah that went to acting
class he was poor and Tarantino worked
at a video store yeah so it's like you
know but it had to have been great yeah
yeah so um that's interesting but you
can't give it anything to a comedian
because we don't want to do anything
I forgot it could be you know uh Titanic
or some Blockbuster we wouldn't we
wouldn't we would throw it in quick
trash even if you did read it would you
think it was good do you know if it's
good or not probably not yeah that's me
too yeah and when people send me scripts
even my agents I give it to her because
when I read it they all seem to sound
good yeah I can't read oh I'm a
reptilian alien enforcement
right the only one guy gave me this
script and I actually ended up making it
it was this two girls one cup
and uh
it was actually very good yeah a lot of
improv it seems like oh yeah
imagine directing that and you go this
one's you do your own take on this one
yeah
it was rich yeah right right maybe
that's how the Poo happened maybe maybe
poop wasn't in the scripture and the
director goes make it your own they're
like I have to take a [__] I might as
well just try
it might have been a war movie
yeah I mean I don't know I I how do you
make porn if you're like if I called you
and I hey dude yeah I met this Wang Wang
he's a Chinese billionaire wait let's
suppose you're going through a comedy
club it's comedy slump ears okay
I get a call from Wong Wong all right
well some Chinese billionaire Oh I
thought that was the phone ringing